[Music]  what may look like a beautiful green  oasis is actually the top of an active  volcano  [Music]  located in java indonesia is the koala  gen volcano  at its top sits a highly acidic crater  lake  the water is 90 degrees fahrenheit and  appears bluish green  no species live in or around the water  as the conditions are too harsh for  nature to survive  at night a rare phenomenon can be seen  unlike any other volcano in the world  koala gen emits what appears to be  bright blue flames  this blue glow is not caused by lava but  instead from a combustion of sulfuric  gasses  once the gas is cool a bright yellow  sulfur forms which is mined and sold  miners use steel bars to break off  portions of the sulfur and carry up to  200 pounds back down the volcano  the emitted gases are toxic if inhaled  making this strenuous work incredibly  dangerous  while this unique volcano may be home to  one of the world's most grueling jobs it  is also a site worth seeing  you